after weeks of delays the promised eggs
from India are finally here on Thursday
the shipment was distributed among
Bakers and confectioners where demand is
highest
with daily consumption up to 7 million
eggs the consignment won't last long the
government hopes it will at least ease
the situation our plan is just to cater
to the bakery industry and the hoteliers
so when we fulfill their requirement
automatically the other eggs the local
producer will come to the market so then
the consumers would able to get the egg
at a competitive price I mean reasonable
price
the poultry industry has supplied local
demand in recent years with eggs last
imported in 2012. but there have been
shortages in recent months and a
tripling of egg prices in just a year
Farmers say a surge in the price of
chicken feed is to blame the result of
fertilizer restrictions and a lack of
foreign currency Farmers say
importing corn was a problem because of
the dollar issue and there was no
locally grown corn because of the ban on
agrochemicals many farms had to close if
they had got raw materials as they
needed this wouldn't have happened many
farms survived the crisis by selling
some of their layer birds for meat as
they couldn't afford to feed them Sri
Lanka's poultry Association says the
government's approach is
self-contradictory on one hand
encouraging local farmers to increase
production while on the other
undermining the very same Farmers by
importing cheap eggs the government says
importing eggs is the best way to
provide consumers some relief from
skyrocketing prices Farmers don't agree
and scientists are also warning of the
dangers of such a move so if in any case
if we import it's from a country where
the influencer avian influencer is
already there there is a possibility
that this virus can come to our poultry
our backyard Paul to our birds and even
it could be sunatic that means it in
severe cases the general public can be
affected India reported infections as
recently as last month in two different
locations but Sri Lankan authorities say
they've imported safety certified eggs
from a disease-free area
over 1 million people depend directly
and indirectly on the poultry industry
the association says the government must
ensure its long-term survival rather
than Chase short-term Solutions
Fernandez Al Jazeera koskama Sri Lanka
well let's take a closer look at this
issue with Jada Thompson she's an
assistant professor of agricultural
economics at the University of Arkansas
she joins us now from Fayetteville Jada
so this is the result of a number of
different courses I know avian flu and
new migratory Parts because of climate
change have been discussed but this is
also an agricultural Supply issue right
exacerbated by government decisions
yes ma'am I mean it's multifaceted you
know you already talk about bird flu
which is affecting you know I think in
the last three weeks like 2.2 million
birds have been depopulated either
because of the disease and then you add
in feed cost you add in a war in Ukraine
affecting wheat prices kind of the
global market for feed sources uh you
you look at the inputs and then I think
they talked about fertilizers and these
different inputs and so what you have is
this exacerbated you know inflationary
costs and labor costs and transportation
that they compound the issues related to
bird flu of course Jada this isn't just
a problem in the US and Europe we've
been hearing also in a number of Asian
countries too I see Japanese restaurants
are now taking egg items off menus and
in many parts of the world eggs are
obviously a hugely important source of
affordable protein so how far could this
spread
so one of the biggest concerns about
this particular outbreak or kind of a
health event
um is that it it didn't stop so
typically we you know we would have
thought maybe at the end of last year we
would have saw some relief and it's
still spreading and it is it's not uh
focused on just on America's it's in
America's Europe Asia
um it it and it's continuing to spread
and we're not seeing an end inside for
that
um and so the problem is it's exactly
it's a cheap protein it's an easy access
and so what happens when the prices rise
is it's a pretty
um you can't you can't substitute away
from the product we're going to need
that is in terms of emulsification we
bake things
um and so we're looking for alternative
Solutions in terms of monitoring
surveillance um but the economic impacts
of this are
um going to continue and I don't think
um we're gonna see extreme relief in the
media future because we're still going
to have to try to control the HPI and
the feed sources are going to have to be
uh dealt with first Jay do you say this
isn't going to be resolved in the short
term how long could prices remain this
High could they potentially get even
higher
um you know we're seeing this like
cyclical movement so I think whenever
you see um some kind of relief in the
outbreaks happening and we see some
relief coming back down
um I can speak to the U.S prices have
that were exceptionally high in November
and December of 2022
um they came down and they're coming
down except for high seasonal demand and
holiday demand around April
um I think that uh you know hopefully
that we're going to figure out the
supply issue and hopefully feed prices
will come down and we'll see a much more
moderated
um a response in terms of the of the
input cost on those so I think in the
medium term we might see some relief
coming
um I don't think we're going to get to
2021 levels anytime in the near future
um and hopefully by the end of the year
we'll see prices that are much more
reasonable and we'll see uh a market
that has a little bit of relief for
consumers Jada Thompson there and
assistant professor of agricultural
economics at the University of Arkansas
thanks so much for sharing your
expertise with us here on now to zero
Jada
thank you